Vous vous en foutez,
de la dissertation de français ?
C’est ce que me disaient
mes amis de Maths sup,
quand j’étais,
moi,
en Prépa HEC.
C’est vrai que vous êtes
en prépa SCIENTIFIQUE,
et puis le coefficient
de la dissertation de français est faible
aux concours des écoles d’ingénieur
— donc OUI,
logiquement,
vous ne devez pas y consacrer
beaucoup de temps.
MAIS
il y a une opportunité :
comme le français
n’est pas le point fort des candidats,
et qu’EN PLUS
ils négligent la matière,
eh bien c’est facile
de sortir du lot !
C’est facile
À DEUX CONDITIONS.
PREMIÈRE condition :
vous devez connaître
LES RÈGLES DU JEU,
c’est-à-dire ce que vous devez savoir
PRÉCISÉMENT,
ce que vous pouvez faire,
et ce vous ne pouvez PAS faire,
pour décrocher une bonne note.
C’est ce dont je vais vous parler
dans cette vidéo :
je vais vous dire TOUT
ce que vous devez savoir
pour réussir la dissertation de français
en prépa scientifique.
Je vais d’abord vous dire
ce que vous devez savoir
SUR L’ÉPREUVE ;
ensuite,
ce que vous devez savoir
SUR LES SUJETS ;
et enfin SUR LES NOTES
et sur les statistiques
des différents concours.
Maintenant,
quelle est la SECONDE CONDITION
pour sortir du lot en français ?
C’est que vous devez maîtriser
la MÉTHODOLOGIE
de la dissertation,
parce que c’est vraiment important
pour les correcteurs de cette épreuve.
Ça tombe bien,
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut :
profitez de mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation.
Vous pouvez vous y inscrire
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Les élèves de prépa scientifique l’adorent,
donc je sais que vous ne serez pas déçu.
Mais bon,
vous n’êtes pas là
pour que je vous parle de méthodo.
QUE devez-vous savoir
sur la dissertation de français
pour réussir vos concours ?
Cette épreuve,
je la connais bien,
parce que j’y prépare des élèves
depuis maintenant plus de dix ans.
Je me souviens par exemple d’Adrien,
que j’ai formé
à ma méthodologie de la dissertation,
et qui a intégré Polytechnique,
l’école de ses rêves.
Mais bon,
assez parlé de moi.
Alors,
vous le savez probablement déjà,
mais la dissertation
est la PREMIÈRE
épreuve de français
aux concours des écoles d’ingénieur
— elle est parfois accompagnée
d’une épreuve de résumé,
comme à Centrale,
par exemple.
Dans cette vidéo,
je ne vais parler QUE
de la dissertation :
d’accord ?
Comme vous êtes des scientifiques,
je vais commencer
avec quelques chiffres
que vous devez connaître :
le coefficient de cette épreuve,
c’est huit pour cent
— ce qui veut dire
que TREIZE POINTS
en français
vous feront gagner
UN SEUL POINT
de moyenne générale.
Je sais :
c’est pas fou.
Second chiffre important :
l’épreuve dure QUATRE HEURES
pour certaines écoles
(l’ENS Paris,
Lyon,
et Cachan,
et bien sûr
Polytechnique) ;
MAIS elle dure
TROIS HEURES
pour d’autres écoles,
comme les Mines Ponts.
Et lorsque l’épreuve
mêle un résumé
et une dissertation,
ou un résumé,
des questions,
et une dissertation
— dans ces cas-là,
vous devez consacrer
AU MOINS DEUX HEURES
à la dissertation.
Cette information est importante,
parce qu’elle implique
que vous devez ADAPTER
votre méthode
à la durée de l’épreuve.
Et ça,
vous ne devez pas
vous en rendre compte le jour J ;
vous devez vous calibrer
par essai et erreur
tout au long de l’année.
Maintenant,
qu’est-ce que vous devez savoir
sur l’exercice lui-même ?
Première chose :
c’est une dissertation
— il s’agit donc de RÉFLÉCHIR,
d’ARGUMENTER,
et de BIEN RÉDIGER.
Le but N’EST PAS
de montrer
que vous connaissez votre cours.
Regardez ce que dit
le rapport de jury de Centrale - Supélec
de 2004 :
« Comme d’autres années
on déplorera des erreurs méthodologiques
trop répandues pour ne pas devenir irritantes.
»
Donc encore une fois,
je vous invite à vous inscrire
pour recevoir mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation.
Voilà,
je ne vous en dis pas plus
sur l’exercice de la dissertation,
parce que j’ai déjà publié une vidéo
à ce sujet.
Elle s’intitule
« Qu’est-ce qu’une dissertation ? »
— vous la trouverez facilement
sur cette chaîne.
SECONDE chose
que vous devez savoir
à propos de la dissertation de français
:
dans votre copie,
vous êtes OBLIGÉS
de prendre appui
SUR LES ŒUVRES
du programme de l’année.
Votre dissertation doit apporter la preuve
que vous connaissez ces œuvres
DANS LE DÉTAIL.
Regardez ce que dit
le rapport de jury des CCP
de 2002 :
« C’est dans le manque de contact individuel
avec les textes au programme
que réside la faiblesse ESSENTIELLE
de l’exercice
dans la plupart des copies.
Beaucoup de candidats donnent l’impression
de n’avoir pas lu vraiment les trois œuvres,
le crayon à la main,
ce qui constitue tout de même
la condition ABSOLUMENT NÉCESSAIRE
pour pouvoir en parler.
»
Alors,
ça ne veut pas dire
que vous devez VRAIMENT
lire les trois œuvres
« CRAYON À LA MAIN »
— ça veut dire
que c’est L’IMPRESSION
que vous devez donner
dans votre copie.
J’en ai terminé
avec ce que vous devez savoir
SUR L’ÉPREUVE.
Maintenant,
je vais vous parler des sujets.
Vous allez devenir des ingénieurs,
donc vous êtes pragmatiques.
Commençons par regarder
les sujets qui sont tombés.
On va regarder ceux qui sont tombés
à Polytechnique - ENS,
à Mines - Ponts,
à Centrale,
et aux CCP.
Voici le sujet tombé à Polytechnique - ENS
en 2020 :
Voici le sujet tombé aux Mines - Ponts,
toujours en 2020 :
Voici le sujet tombé à Centrale :
Et enfin,
voici le sujet tombé aux CCP :
Alors,
qu’est-ce que vous devez savoir
à propos des sujets ?
Vous devez retenir
TROIS CHOSES.
La première,
c’est que ce sont toujours
DES CITATIONS.
Ce ne sont pas des citations
des œuvres au programme,
et parfois le sujet
ne précise pas le nom de l’auteur.
C’est IMPORTANT
que vous gardiez à l’esprit
que le sujet sera une citation,
parce qu’on ne traite pas
de la même manière
un sujet - citation
et un sujet qui consiste en une question,
ou encore en une locution.
Donc VOUS,
vous devez acquérir
une méthodologie de la dissertation
ADAPTÉE
aux sujets - citations.
DEUXIÈME chose
que vous devez retenir
à propos des sujets :
les citations peuvent être LONGUES.
La citation
du sujet de Polytechnique de 2020
fait 46 mots,
ce qui est très long
pour une phrase.
Celle du sujet de Mines - Ponts
fait 45 mots
— c’est pareil,
c’est très long.
Et en plus,
ce sont des phrases COMPLIQUÉES.
La conséquence POUR VOUS,
c’est que vous devrez être capables
de SYNTHÉTISER
et de SIMPLIFIER
l’idée ESSENTIELLE
de la citation.
Ça vous permettra ensuite
de trouver le problème intellectuel
à résoudre dans la dissertation.
TROISIÈME CHOSE
que vous devez retenir
à propos des sujets :
il y a une phrase
qui est là pour vous guider,
mais elle ne sert à rien.
Par exemple,
sur le sujet de Polytechnique - ENS
de 2020,
c’était :
« Vous commenterez et discuterez ce propos
en vous appuyant sur des exemples précis
empruntés notamment aux œuvres du programme..
»
Il n’y a aucune consigne PRÉCISE
dans cette phrase.
Et c’était pareil à Mines - Ponts,
et à Centrale.
Il n’y a qu’aux CCP
que la phrase invite le candidat
à critiquer l’affirmation
de l’auteur de la citation.
Donc la troisième chose
que vous devez retenir,
c’est que la phrase de consigne
qui accompagne la citation
ne sert à rien.
Concentrez-vous donc
EXCLUSIVEMENT
sur la citation.
Voilà pour les sujets.
Il est temps de parler des notes !
Je vais vous donner
les statistiques ESSENTIELLES
pour l’épreuve de Polytechnique - ENS,
pour celle de Mines - Ponts,
pour celle de Centrale,
et pour celle des CCP.
On commence par l’épreuve
de Polytechnique - ENS.
Pour résumer,
la moyenne était autour de DIX
en 2019,
un peu supérieur à dix
en 2018,
et encore autour de dix
en 2017.
Donc grosso modo
c’est autour de dix
ces dernières années.
Notez que la moyenne de la filière PC
est 0,5
à 0,75
points inférieure.
En synthèse,
pour l’épreuve Polytechnique - ENS,
les moyennes tournent autour de dix,
alors que la barre d’admissibilité
est entre douze
et treize.
Concernant Mines - Ponts,
maintenant,
les statistiques ne sont malheureusement pas,
ou plus disponibles.
Concernant l’épreuve de Centrale,
la moyenne était grosso modo
entre neuf
et dix
en 2020,
presque 10,5
en 2019
— sauf pour la filière TSI
dont la moyenne était 9,5 ;
et enfin
c’était la même chose en 2018,
sauf pour la filière TSI
dont la moyenne était à neuf.
Donc les moyennes sont
entre neuf et dix,
alors que les barres d’admissibilité sont,
selon les écoles,
entre dix
et treize.
Concernant les CCP,
enfin,
les moyennes de l’épreuve
étaient ces dernières
entre 9,5
et 10,5.
Et comme il y a
PLUS DE TRENTE écoles
dans ce concours commun,
eh bien il y a plein
de barres d’admissibilité différentes.
— vous trouverez celles qui vous intéressent
sur internet.
Voilà,
je vous ai donné
les statistiques essentielles.
Qu’est-ce que vous devez en retenir
pour préparer l’épreuve
de dissertation de français ?
Vous devez d’abord retenir
que ce n’est pas compliqué
d’avoir dix.
Le gros des copies
se situe entre neuf et dix,
ou bien autour de dix,
donc vous pourrez atteindre ces notes
SANS ÊTRE
particulièrement bien préparé.
La SECONDE CHOSE
que vous devez retenir des statistiques,
c’est que
si vous ambitionnez L’ADMISSIBILITÉ
aux bonnes
et aux très bonnes écoles,
alors vous devez viser
AU MOINS TREIZE.
Et là,
vous ne pouvez pas
négliger votre préparation.
SI vous visez plus de treize,
SI vous voulez sortir
du VENTRE MOU
des copies,
alors vous avez besoin
d’une méthodologie
SOLIDE,
comme celle qu’il y a
dans mon cours gratuit par e-mail
— c’est une méthodologie
que j’ai conçue
pour être SOLIDE
mais aussi SIMPLE.
Je vous conseille donc de vous inscrire
à mon cours GRATUIT
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant en haut à droite
de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description de cette vidéo.
Allez,
c’est l’heure de conclure !
Alors,
qu’est-ce que vous pouvez retenir
de cette vidéo ?
Pour faire simple,
retenez trois choses :
PREMIÈRE CHOSE,
les correcteurs veulent
que vous rédigiez
UNE VÉRITABLE DISSERTATION
et vous devez donner l’impression
que vous connaissez les œuvres au programme
DANS LE DÉTAIL ;
DEUXIÈME CHOSE,
les sujets seront des citations
LONGUES
et COMPLIQUÉES,
donc vous devrez êtes capables
de SYNTHÉTISER
et de SIMPLIFIER
l’idée essentielle
de la citation ;
TROISIÈME
et dernière chose,
il sera « facile »,
entre guillemets,
d’atteindre DIX,
MAIS vous devez viser TREIZE,
pour être admissible
aux meilleures écoles.
Et encore une fois,
la clé pour réussir
cette dissertation de français,
c’est LA MÉTHODOLOGIE.
Voilà voilà,
j’espère que cette vidéo
vous sera utile.
Je suis Romain,
je suis toujours avec mon fidèle Haristote,
et vous étiez
sur 1000 idées de culture générale.
Rappelez-vous
que vous n’avez pas besoin
de vous prendre la tête
pour réussir
la dissertation de français
en prépa scientifique.